fait sa rentrée fait leur entrée mirial
bien là assieds toi c'est très bien je
vais te poser des questions qui vont
peut-être te sembler étrange mais
contente toi d'y répondre et de dire la
vérité
comment as tu connu moïse il sait bien
comment je les connais alors tu n'es pas
sa soeur comme on dit
bien sûr que non bos tombera sur la
table am sert s'y arrête tout de suite
avec tout de suite sinon quoi c'est un
conseil que je donne tu es sûr de ce que
tu t'apprêtes à faire si tu comptes dans
servi un félin alors
alors je peux continuer myriam je te
reposes la question une dernière fois et
si tu réponds encore non pardonne moi
pour ce qui se passera ensuite
est ce que tu es sa soeur
et non
ouais